This episode of DNews is brought to you by
Bluum.
This may be a bit of "no duh, science," but
gals, "Science says that you are JUST AS GOOD
AS GUYS!"
Yay!!!
Good day ladies and gentlemen, Trace here
for DNews.
There is a lot of underlying cultural interplay
between men and women.
The pay equality gap is just one example,
but a visible one.
A study out of Stanford in 1998 asked women
and men to write an article, and then later
asked how much they would pay themselves for
the work.
Women routinely asked for 18-percent less
than the men.
Not because they WANTED less money, but because
they didn't compare their rates to men, but
only to their fellow women.
This was compounded by already existing pay
gaps.
Using THAT as a starting point, why don't
people get a fair comparison?
Again, we already know it's not that women
undervalue themselves, because a study from
Cornell that removed the names and sex from
equally qualified candidates found universities
were more likely to tenure and hire men.
The problem is systemic, but this MIGHT be
starting to change.
Again, might.
A meta-analysis in the Journal of Applied
Psychology studied tens of thousands of leaders
across a barrage of scientific papers and
found men and women are rated EQUALLY as effective
leaders.
EQUALLY.
As long as you don't ask them to rate themselves.
They found when you ask a good leader to rate
themselves: men tend to think they're EXTREMELY
effective and women thought of themselves
as less so.
However, when OTHER people doling the assessment,
both men and women were rated about the same.
The researchers believe the difference is
the globalization and modernization of the
workforce.
Women are more likely to be in positions of
power than ever, and they're CRUSHING IT.
Of course, if you REALLY look back, you probably
already knew this was coming.
When I was in elementary school everyone KNEW
the girls were smarter.
We just did.
And ANOTHER study in Psychological Bulletin
analyzed the grades of boys versus girls from
1914 to 2011 in 30 countries and found girls
did BETTER in math and science for the ENTIRE
CENTURY.
The scientists who did the study were shocked.
They think somehow, we all just... weren't
looking at the data and instead assumed boys
were better at math and science because there
were MORE boys in those fields as adults.
So if women are equally good leaders, better
in school and graduating from high school
and college in record numbers, why is there
still inequality in the workplace?
Unfortunately that's still a mystery.
But maybe with science like this, we can educate
ourselves to equality.
What do you think of all this?
Tell us your thoughts on equality, leadership
and the future down below.
I know that's a tall order, but I think you
can handle it.
Speaking of tall orders, what about being
a Mom.
Baby stuff is weird and difficult for some
to wrap their head around, so Bluum does it
for you!
Not literally, they know all about the soft
spot on your baby head.
Bluum is a box subscription services tailored
to the age, sex and development of your little
bundle of joy.
They deliver boxes of bath and body stuff,
toys, food, clothing -- you name it -- right
to your door!
Why fight the crowds and go to the mall to
compete with the double-wide off-road strollers
when you could have it shopped and sent to
you.
Go to bluum.com/dnews and use the code REV3
for half off your first month and discounts
for subscriptions!
Plus, it supports the show.
Thanks for watching DNews!